hey did you know that 15 minutes could
save you 15% or more on car insurance
everybody already knows that couch
tomato oh really well did you know that
when you were animal print clothing and
show up fashionably late it means your
outfit mister period when I was a little
kid I always thought the only way you
could become an underage superhero was
to be bit by a radioactive spider or
Jordan had to recruit a team of
teenagers with attitude I stand
corrected because I later found out that
if you disrespect your elders like
talking back to your parents sneaking
into your mom's room without permission
and locking your dad out of a room in a
house that he pays the bills for more
than likely you'll be moving objects
without the use of your hands in three
months or less just like the kid in this
movie do not try and bend the spoon
that's impossible
instead only try to realize the truth
there is no spoon but anyways once upon
a time in a city where the only thing to
do was to record people without their
permission using the same video camera
that Jesus them used to vlog with live
the dad who called out sick every
father's day and just sat around the
living room watching TV all day
this had a negative impact on the kid at
first it's nothing major just victimless
crimes like purposely forgetting to cite
sources on the works cited page of his
research papers but it gets worse later
on in the film the parenting that the
kid was missing out at at home is
substituted with guidance from his peers
the main character makes friends with
the coolest black kid in school cliche
yeah but the black kid is a positive
role model because ebony is always
coming up with great ideas on how to get
high and stuff not like drugs or
anything but the other kind of high that
you get when you know someone with gene
greyish like capabilities for the most
part the main character circle of
friends aren't bad kids we get examples
of their acts of kindness when they
organize adventures in the woods for
team-building exercises and it's one
part in the school auditorium where the
literal or figurative biggest loser in
the school goes up on stage and it's
about to be embarrassing for the guy but
one of the main characters friends start
egging on the crowd to clap firm and
stuff all this young adult love can't
really substitute for the adult kind you
miss out on when you have a father who
doesn't care that's why it's no surprise
to me at least that the main character
turns to a life of felonies this one
night when the kid with powers decides
enough is enough
dew puts on a coat grabs a bag and goes
to commit some robberies
the feeling you get when you get to use
your abilities on people without special
powers feels good I'm guessing only
because when the kid realizes they're an
apex predator they start torturing
creatures lower on the food chain and
the kid sticks the middle finger to the
whole turn-the-other-cheek nonsense
when avenging his or her self by popping
their bully in the mouth after that the
movie takes a heart left and goes dark
for a second when we discover that
someone commits a murder and gets away
with it
it's here we're a close confidant is
like you gotta be careful stay out of
trouble follow these rules and why not
although a convincing argument the
person giving the advice does come off
as a goody-goody and know-it-all which
is why when they try to reason with
people earlier in the movie they usually
get a door slammed in their face later
on there's this part where the bad guy
throws a dude out of a window and one of
the kids with powers catches him before
he dies the villain starts losing their
temper and it's a shame because it sets
a bad example and lots of little kids
are watching the whole thing at the end
when the cops show up you hear police
sirens getting closer and closer and it
brings up a serious question if you're
not guilty why the hell are you running
for sure bro those are 24 reasons these
movies are the same you agree Yes No
maybe so if not politely share your
thoughts in the comment section below
and click the subscribe button for more
24 reason videos